يمكننا الاقتراب اكثر من الموقع نعم دائما
هناك امل كما يقولون هنا في هذا الموقع
لاسيما ان الاخبار تتوالى من بين فينه
واخرى عن انقاذ احياء في بعض المناطق قبل
قليل يعني قبل دقائقنا الان تم الاعلان عن
انقاذ طفله في ولايه كهرمان مرعش صمدت تحت
الانقاض لمده تسع وتسعين ساعه تم اخراجها
قبل قليل في ولايه كهرمان مرعش هذه
الانباء دائما تعطي يعني شعور ايجابي لدى
جميع طواقم
الانقاذ العامله ان كانت هنا في كهرمان
مرعش او حتى هنا في اضنه او في بقيه
الولايات هنا في هذا الموقع الذي نتواجد
فيه الان وهو موقع لبناء مدمر كان البناء
مكون من 14 طابقا وسط مدينه اضنه
الخميس يعني قبل حوالي 24 ساعه تم اخراج
احد الاشخاص وهو مازال على قيد الحياه كان
هناك يعني توقعات بوجود اشخاص اخرين لذلك
استمرت عمليات البحث وتم جلب طواقم متخصصه
وتم فحص الموقع بكاميرات مراقبه حراريه
ويحاولون حتى هذه اللحظه استكمال عمليات
البحث في محاوله للوصول الى ناجين لكن مع
هذه المحاولات دائما هناك مع الاسف اعداد
الضحيه تستمر
وهناك انتشال للجثث في هذا الموقع الذي
نتواجد فيه الان
منذ الليله الماضيه وحتى فجر هذا اليوم تم
انتشال خمس جثث تعتقد السلطات هنا او فرق
الانقاذ انها لعائله واحده احد الاشخاص
الذي شارك في هذه العمليه اخبرني ان الجثث
هي لاب وام وطفلين وايضا سيده كبيره في
العمر يعتقدون انها
الطفلين اخبرني ان الاطفال احد الاطفال
كان جاثيا ومنكمشا على ما يبدو انه كان
جاثيا على ركبتيه حين انهار المبنى يعني
هذا ما وصفه لي احد الاشخاص الذي كان
قريبا من فرق الانقاذ وكان شاهدا على
اخراجهم قال لي انهم كانوا قريبين جدا من
بعض وبالتالي هذا ما رجح الاعتقاد بانهم
من عائله واحده كما قلنا يعني مع الاسف
يعني اخبار سيئه وهذا ينبئ بان حصيله
الضحايا ربما سترتفع اكثر من ذلك لكن في
العموم اذا عدنا الى ولايه اضنه والسؤال
الذي طرحته علي قبل قليل نعم الاعمال في
ولايه اضنه تقترب من الانتهاء هذا ما اكده
نائب الرئيس التركي فؤاد اوكتاي لكن يعني
موضوع تقترب من الانتهاء ليس خلال ساعات
انا كنت صرحت او كنت قلت في نشرات سابقه
انها ربما تنتهي خلال ساعات لكن احد
الطواقم الانقاذ اخبرني انها ربما تستمر
حتى يوم الاثنين